meantime Nevada's first all-girls school
plans to open this fall even during the
pandemic it's a charter middle school
located on the campus of UNLV 8 news now
reporter Kristin Drummond is live in the
newsroom now with the latest on the
option for families Kristin
Sascha it's called girls Athletic
Leadership School or gals Las Vegas the
middle school plans to welcome sixths
and 7th graders this fall and eighth
graders next year
school leaders plan to continue to
accept applications and recently noticed
an uptick following the Clark County
School District revealing its
back-to-school kovat plan a surge of
interest in Nevada's first all-girls
charter school really everything
Angelina Ortiz is part of the inaugural
gals class choosing to come here this
fall after attending a CCSD middle
school there was a lot of boys where I
couldn't really get a really good
education there he's really loud she
welcomes the all-girls model that
incorporates physical education with
academics the school plans to open in
August at the Boys and Girls Club of
Southern Nevada on the UNLV campus we
want our children to see themselves in
college this is important it's a part of
their life helping students visualize a
higher education school leaders also
focus on opening during kovat 19 a plan
online outlines various options
including in-person instruction five
days a week with distance learning every
girl will get their own Chromebook so
the technology is there immediately
we're not waiting to get it it will be
there day one we have purchased
interactive software their content
teacher will be directly on the other
end on campus clear partitions separate
desks providing comfort for some parents
who want their student in a classroom
the classes are smaller so the teacher
will have
or FaceTime with her offering a location
to encourage young women to thrive and
achieve their dreams I think I will try
my hardest to get into college the
school eventually plans to enroll a
total of 400 students and enrollment is
still open for anyone interested
reporting live in the newsroom Kristin
Drummond 8 News now